[Música]
bom eu estou me sentindo bem à vontade
que percebi que eu investiria de teatro
pra vocês estão caráter e eu vim falar
da grande revolução umbanda e nem outra
é e nenhum outro espaço tempo nesse
planetinha de terceira dimensão chamado
terra tanto se falou e tanto se buscou a
revolução interna
tudo isso para responder a uma simples
pergunta tinha o que é que eu tô a 0 e
depois algumas perguntinhas um pouco
mais complexas que é assim houve votou
no gol mineiro e que eu me preparei pela
omt em tese na 31ª vez com a frase você
colhe o que planta
eu não sei vocês mas eu já ouvi esse vai
ditar ditado popular inúmeras vezes mas
ele tem definitivamente só fez sentido
pra mim pois uma certa dose de paciência
que só a maturidade e o conhecimento
prático parece bem óbvio dizer que é
impossível plantar feijão e colombo j
isso é exatamente o que eu fiz quando eu
passei mais da metade da minha vida
sendo reativo
eu simplesmente reagir ao externo com
julgando procrastinando a rua do
culpados para as linhas estreitas
terceirizando as responsabilidades da
minha vida para os outros e aí você age
ou você reage criança minha mãe foi
trabalhar e diz vai chover eu só estava
lá mas vou demais e já sabem né é
bendito publicar o meu sonho é ser
apresentadora cantora paquita essas
coisas mas ele choveu ea roupa olhou
o que a minha mãe fez ela me bateu na
pele a vara de marmelo e o que eu fiz eu
fugi
eu fui morar com meu pai nessa época os
meus pais eram separados eo morar com
eles que ó mais ou menos umas duas
semanas até que ela buscou pela peça que
trouxe de volta o bom pois meu primeiro
emprego de carteira assinada
era o sonho da minha mãe eu tenho
serviço de carteira assinada até hoje
acho que eu sou meio louco porque eu não
tenho serviço de carteira assinada
mas enfim três meses de trabalho a
gerente de uma loja chegou louca sendo
dada dentro da roupa metendo a maluca
gritando feito baiano inclusive comigo
eu era vendedor de sapatos muito nervosa
irritada com o mundo inteiro o que eu
fiz e de emissão
eu fugi de morro e eu fiz isso em todos
os meus empregos xampus e frentes sem
perceber isso o padrão acabou
acontecendo em todas as áreas da minha
vida
no fundo eu não sabia o que estava
plantando e muito menos por que eu
gostaria de colher
bom eu nem o tempo porque eu trabalhei
por quatro meses uma empresa sem receber
salário
olha eu parei e comecei a me questionar
o que é que eu tô fazendo aqui um mês
sem dinheiro nem para comprar um litrão
no final de semana para dar uma
desinteressada
eu comecei a me questionar quando eu
posso trabalhar motivada
mesmo sem receber tem um tostão foi eu
comecei a me questionar o plantio que eu
quero fazer é aí que eu entendi uma
frase muito o joelho me ajudou nesse
processo que é a seguinte o que
aconteceu que eu fique com o flamengo
porque todas as vezes que uma pessoa
infeliz vier vou evitar todas as
frustrações dela em você você para
respira colega com o seu momento
presente e disse pra ela mentalmente
fica aconteceu que eu fique compreender
simplesmente libertador
afinal de contas nem gente não fazendo
conta de resolver nem as próprias tretas
que dirá as tropas alheias
então você deixa a pessoa que é dela e
ray resolver os seus próprios problemas
e aí nessa empresa
eu comecei a me questionar como é
trabalhar com ativada
como eu poderia fazer um pontinho
diferente do que eu estava perdendo aí
eu me propus a trabalhar e fazer o
melhor que eu pudesse gente não era
fácil tá ela tinha 11 jogadores na porta
da empresa de cinco em cinco minutos
no ranking dos funcionários quase que
diariamente e até ameaças de morte eram
freqüentes
mas eu propus a fazer o meu trabalho da
melhor forma que eu pudesse então eu
ajudei a se enrolar muita treta e houve
muita graça
pode não parecer mas eu sou a rainha da
palhaçada eu lhe diria que a freqüência
da alegria é uma das melhores
frequências para elevar e deixar o outro
o que é dele
bom aí eu percebi que eu conseguia
controlar o meu estado terra a quem essa
empresa por mais um tempo
no mesmo estágio de um amigo que
trabalha comigo chegou pra mim disse
a partir de hoje eu não faço mais na axé
fies educação sem noção arrogante
enquanto ele não mudar o jeito de tratar
as pessoas
então ele não fizer xixi solução para
alterar o quadro da empresa eu não faço
na oportunidade eu peguei uma agenda e
eu treinar ele diz que representa a sua
vida
já na mesa do chef joga na mesa dele e
fala assim
isso representa a minha vida na hora que
você resolveu fazer alguma coisa na hora
que você tomar alguma atitude em relação
à empresa não tem aviso urgente ele foi
muito bem no time da globo
adu e também sim impura que ele não está
com a agenda no meio da minha peça não
posso fazer isso ele falou
ué mas é exatamente isso que você está
fazendo
o plantio é seu e você quer que ele
planta tipo você é isso que nós fazemos
quando reagimos ao externo é isso que
nós fazemos quando eu quero que os
políticos não lembra que eu mude
é isso que eu faço quando eu quero que a
crise passe para quem prefere é isso que
acontece quando eu quero que o meu
marido múltipla quinta que eu me sinto
bem e jogar a responsabilidade da sua
vida nas mãos do outro
[Música]
eu tenho uma notícia lamentável e não é
responsável pelas suas escolhas
então você entregar a responsabilidade
da sua vida na mão do outro você está
afastado acolher o que ele estiver afim
de tom e aí você não tem que deixar
alguém fazer por você tem que deixar que
não tem aquilo que você quer que venha
qualquer coisa
bom eu percebi que era reativa em mais
da metade da minha vida querendo me
adaptar ao meio externo
eu queria fazer parte eu queria
pertencer lhe chegam da luz dia que você
percebe que você não precisa agradar rei
você não precisa agradar aí você percebe
que você não precisa ser aceito pela
sociedade
ei você não precisa ser aceito
você não sabe que nem para agradar e nem
ter aceito você está aqui para cumprir o
propósito diferenciar os a sua vida da
melhor maneira que você puder até dizer
então já que ela possa que eu não
preciso agradar e que não precisa ser
aceita eu posso sair do país chegando a
pessoa
se lesada na rua op você pode tudo mas
nem tudo você tem que sair xingando
reclamando jugan faz parte de seus
objetivos
então continue lembre-se você escolhe o
que ponto e agora se você é aquela
pessoa aquele cidadão que anda por aí
desfilando torceu veneno em cima das
pessoas e disse contando toda sua ira eu
tenho que te dizer eu posso prever o seu
futuro
gente basta olhar o seu plantio que
alencar passe fácil pra mim cigana pita
descobrir seu futuro você é exata entre
o vencedor da acontecer já ou seja eu
sei exatamente o que eu sei
irá acolher o seu plantio me conta a sua
história
bom eu realmente passei muito tempo da
minha vida sendo reativo
mas aí eu percebi que valeu muito a pena
que botou o pé na frente de tristeza
cada feira que eu passei cada preta que
eu passei
cada valeu a pena trabalhar tomados
meses sem receber nada e principalmente
valeu a pena é plantar a semente que
plantei conscientemente estão fazendo um
ótimo volante ele diz porque hoje eu
estou lendo tudo que eu contei e também
fazendo a minha própria revolução humana
correndo e dando excelentes de luz junto
com vocês nunca pé
para já
obrigado
[Música]